hallo mein name ist luca und wir denken
heute eine frau nachdem das sicher jeder
youtuber schon irgendwie gespielt habe
habe ich mir gedacht ich zeig dir doch
einfach mal wie das so wirklich geht ja
so wir sind jetzt im spiel und versuchen
jetzt einfach mal dieses jahr sind
komischer name alter die versuchen wir
jetzt mal für uns zu gewinnen
ahaus skis expecting also das ist ihr
haus und sie erwartet und das ist quasi
ja hallo war okay wir kommen jetzt mal
rein ariel exchange or better
komplimente lux samt in smart sales
company gefragt wie umarmen liege direkt
drei kinder ist wir können sogar station
macht einfach mal ein safety slot ich
glaub das ist nicht wie oft kann man das
denn sichern alter laser entwickelt
ja danke ich bin wirklich er so der
direkt hier um am typ kissel ja kommt
ist ob das geklappt hat dafür die
alphatiere geküsst haben horst vor
er könnte etwa save your kisses war die
ccs die wir uns lieber wenn man es
lieber bei google eingibt kommt
salewa
arriva ist gar kein baby und auch keine
rockband sondern das ist englisch und
steht für speicher wieder wie toll ich
in der schule auf handys umgefallen also
ich würde einfach mal sagen da wir
direkt auch schon so krass angefangen
wenn wir schon ins bett gehen wollen
müssen wir irgendwo anfangen und sie
sagt
englisch ist dass dieses vor hat jack
white the gentleman danke
okay wir können uns aussuchen was wir
heute machen wir machen muss die münze
die hier gelebt habe so ein scheiß mein
ganzes geld ist weg ich wünschte einfach
mein geld wird in meiner tasche sex
haben und sich vermehren was rede ich
hier schon wieder also ich hab ein
bisschen geld gefunden
ich habe hier ein ein euro stück und
schere lassen erst mal komplett raus nur
[ __ ] neben schwere zahl bedeutet
stein und adler bedeutet papier lemmy du
direkt okay wir haben was bedeutete dass
nochmal ich meine das war paper blitz
europa kann was rock you when you once
you get what you first whisky willing
konnten aus finden der letzten driving
oscar dem local worker torhüter sich
dieser lage in amerika wo diese
halbnackten frauen noch komplett ja
tatsächlich ich hatte nicht die entweder
sie bezahlt oder ich bezahle kommt ich
bin gentleman weil ich bezahle sagte
mirbeth ab wir essen erst mal
ich bin eigentlich überhaupt nicht denn
auch heute also nackte frau bin
überhaupt nicht der mensch bekommt
demand ich will lieber lava und blabla
deswegen sagen wir taktisch in gettorf
get to know what we talk about watching
you have sex with what i want to playing
physical activity flaig 6 wir können
noch nicht mit ok wir fragen setzen
positiv ist auch richtig scharf auf mich
ich will einfach nach dem okay wir haben
als antwortmöglichkeiten welche filme
wir schauen ein moslem comedys ein
integrales alex müller independent films
for rain films we watched at 5 hero
pornos
ich habe ich es gemacht mit allerdings
mann ich will das einfach nur durch
kriegen damit ich mit ihr bisschen
lagern kann halo super mit nach hause
wir fahren nach hause zu ihr kam auf
einmal sind wir nicht zum art museum mit
während das gemahl zwei sowas
entscheidet natürlich wieder moment das
funktioniert gar nicht das sind drei
antwortmöglichkeiten der hat nur zwei
mal ist de gass adler ist mathis und
renault ist wenn der hier drauf und
matisse ist damit gekommen das heißt
mathiaschitz euro man mit painted it a
das sieht doch genau aus wie du rer ich
will seine kunst kenner wissen
der verfehlte antrag bei kabel mehr war
he started in germany und emigrierte
frauen speedway horst born
das könnte man den schnell google neben
also google sagt mir dass tatsächlich
nichts ich rate jetzt einfach mal und
sagt apel ist typisch russischen ok
kommen aus uns doch einfach ins bett
gehen vielleicht bei uci kat oder
smarties came for monetary and a half
men first class und first aid kit ariane
schief meint roger moore
das war's okay tut mir leid youtuber
leaders gesehen haben ich war doch nicht
besser als ihr möchtet ihr dass ich noch
mal probieren
definitiv nein ok wenn es euch gefallen
hat und ihr eventuell wollte dass ich
die sie mal total von der dings und dann
übel sondern er dann bewertet das video
mit einem daumen nach oben und ja